DON DODGE: Hello everyone.
Welcome to the session.
I do this session every year,
and it's always packed.
So it's great to see
you all here.
This is about how to take an
idea from a weekend hack to a
funded start-up.
And I have a great panel here
of people who have done it
themselves, who have invested
in companies like that, and
who are today professional
venture capitalists.
So let's start by introducing
the panel.
Rich Miner, tell us
about yourself.
RICH MINER: Sure, so a
background in computer science.
Have done a couple of
start-ups, been
around for a while.
My first one was in
the early '90s.
Actually even before then I
helped a guy starting a
company called Avid Technology,
which is a video
editing system that most of
the videos you see were
created on.
I did that while I was
at university.
Then I started another company
called Wild Fire
Communications, which I sold
to Orange, European mobile
phone company.
And then started a venture fund
for them, invested in
some companies.
One of them was run by this
guy called Andy Rubin, a
company called Danger.
Kept in touch with Andy and then
co-founded a company with
him called Android, which I sold
to Google, and then have
helped Google get Google
Ventures going.
Now I invest in start-ups.
DON DODGE: Kevin Rose probably
needs no introduction, but
tell us a little bit.
KEVIN ROSE: Sure, been
doing the start-up
thing for since 2004.
Started Digg, a social news
site, also Revision 3, Pownce,
Milk, Oink.
We follow a ton of little
fun crazy projects.
And started angel investing
probably about three years ago
and have since joined Google
and moved on as a venture
partner in Google Ventures.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I'm Naval I'm
the founder and CEO of Angel
List, and prior to that I was an
entrepreneur and co-author
of Venture Hacks and started
companies and everything,
being from optical amplifiers
and dot-coms and made
investors money, lost investors
money, made money,
lost money, lose money.
Now helping other people
make and lose money.
DON DODGE: Excellent, OK, so
you're all entrepreneurs,
started multiple companies.
You're angel investors and have
invested in many companies.
Two of you are now
professional VCs.
What do you look for when
you make an investment?
What are those things?
Is it the team?
Is it the product?
Is it the idea?
Tell us what you look for when
you make a decision.
KEVIN ROSE: So personally I like
ideas that are just big,
groundbreaking new ideas.
Every time there's a pop in the
industry, something like a
Pinterest or a Groupon or you
name it, you see 50, 100 other
ideas along that
genre of idea.
And 99% of the time those
will never succeed.
Those are just people that
are copying other ideas.
The one time that I actually
did see that work was when
Yammer took Twitter and made it
into a business platform.
But oftentimes those
just fizzle out.
So something that's
just potentially--
something that just hasn't
been done before.
I'm tired of seeing the
same thing over and
over and over again.
DON DODGE: But I would remind
you, Google was probably the
12th search engine, maybe 15th
search engine that came along.
KEVIN ROSE: Sure, but the page
rank was a completely new way
of looking at how to rank
documents, though, right?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Also, I
think Google never--
I had the misfortune of knowing
Larry and Sergey from
the early days and
not showing up.
And at least my sense at the
time was it was in no way
derivative.
They did not say we are
the AltaVista of x.
They never described
themselves as such.
So I just thought they thought
of it as something
fundamentally different.
I would echo what Kevin said.
You definitely want big ideas.
But frankly ideas are
a dime a dozen.
And a lot of the recently
celebrated success cases and
exits like Instagram
and Yammer and
Omgpop were all pivots.
And the thing that I'm learning
myself doing Angel
List, which is an enormous
struggle, all start-ups are,
but this is like the biggest
struggle ever for me--
the thing I've realized is that
determination matters
more than almost
anything else.
If you stick with something to
the bitter end, and if you're
smart, and you're working in a
big space, and you just do not
give up, I think you'll have a
better outcome than people who
are looking for that pop.
So in a sense, I reject the
premise of the title of this
panel, which is I don't think
you should take your weekend
hack into a start-up, because
a real start-up is a 5 or 10
year commitment of your life.
It's like getting married
but worse.
Without a lot of the
intermediate upside.
There's a lot less
sex involved.
RICH MINER: It would depend on
the marriage, by the way.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yes,
that's right.
It does depend on
the marriage.
And in many cases harder to get
divorced from a start-up
because you're divorcing
your entire network.
So I would not go from a weekend
hack to a start-up
unless that weekend hack is
something you were deeply,
deeply, deeply passionate
about.
And you are now in
Silicon Valley.
You are competing against the
best people in the world who
have been attracted from all
around the world, doing what
they do best.
Ninety-ninth percentile
is not good enough.
If you're a 99th percentile,
you will go home
in tears and ruin.
So you need to be a
99.99 percentile.
And the way you get there is
by being obsessed with
something, so that
is all you do.
And you shouldn't bother
building a start-up with
anything you're not
obsessed about.
So it is this perfect storm of,
you have to have the right
knowledge, you have to be
teamed up with the right
people, you have to be
working on something
you really care about.
Coincidentally it also has to
be big, because a lot of us
are passionate about things
that are not world
changing in the end.
It has to be relatively
unique.
The timing has to be good.
Your execution has
to be flawless.
You have to be teamed up
with the right people.
And even then you're probably
better off being a venture
capitalist as far as the
economics are concerned.
So you really got
to be into it.
RICH MINER: I want to emphasize
one thing, which is
the people that was mentioned,
because typically for me
that's almost even first
and foremost
above the idea itself.
And people is best if it's
team, not individual.
And even the data shows this,
that founding teams are better
than individual founders.
That doesn't mean as a sole
founder you shouldn't be
pushing forward your idea, but
you should definitely get
teamed up with great people,
because for me it's often a
gut feel as to, this might be
a good idea, but frankly, I
don't think this team
can execute on it.
I'll likely not invest,
no matter how
much I like the idea.
At the same time, if I think
that somebody has something
but it doesn't seem quite
right, but I'm really
impressed with the team, where
it's a crowded space where
other people have gone into
it, but they have a slide
twist on it, and I'm really
impressed with the team--
and I think that was probably
the case with Google, with
Larry and Sergey.
I think people saw, yes this is
search and search-like, but
there's some really bright
people here with a different
way of looking at it.
And so founding teams I think
for a lot of investors is
definitely something that's
up there in importance.
And in fact, a lot of people say
it's the people, people,
people is the top three
things they look at.
DON DODGE: They do.
They say team, idea, market,
which of those--
do all of them have
to be present?
Do you have to have a
demonstrable product?
What stage do you get involved
and what are the most
important factors in
your decision?
RICH MINER: The litmus test I
do is, do I like the team?
Does this seem like an idea
that I can understand?
Do I think that team understands
who they're going
to target market that idea to,
what the population of that
group is, and how they're going
to start targeting some
initial segment of it?
And then ideally, if they do
that, do you believe there's
some way that you
can make money.
And if you look at the dollars
times the market times who of
that market they think they can
address, does that look
like an interesting business?
And those are sort of the
quick back of the
envelope I'll do.
And you don't need to have all
of those things if you're
blown away by a couple of them
and they're missing something,
but you think they'll
figure it out.
And oftentimes it's how do they
make money, especially in
consumer internet.
But if you really think they
can blow something up big,
typically money follows.
That's not necessarily a good
answer for you to have.
You want to have thought it
through a little bit.
But you don't have to have,
here's our 30 year revenue.
That's not going to be
believable anyways.
DON DODGE: Kevin,
any thoughts.
KEVIN ROSE: Yeah, I think that
in consumer Internet plays
oftentimes they don't really
have a business model.
I remember when I first saw
Instagram and sat down with
Kevin, I wanted to invest.
He really wasn't even thinking
about revenue at that point.
But it was clear that
he had so much.
He had a little seed of
traction, and I could just
tell that how quickly he was
spreading over the course of I
think he had been launched
for probably about
two or three weeks.
He already had great numbers.
And there was no one
else in that space.
So he was kind of the
first to the space.
It was super simple,
lightweight,
elegant, easy to use.
He put a lot of emphasis
on performance.
Doing a lot of the uploading
of the images in the
background, so from a user
experience it was
really clean and fast.
In that case I wanted to go in
based solely on the fact that
he was just really executing
and building something that
was first to market.
But, yeah I agree in that
team is most important.
There was an investment I did
in a company called Yobongo,
which this guy, the CEO Caleb,
smart early 20-somethings
entrepreneur that blew me away
when we sat down and we had
some coffee.
And he was just this
phenomenal, really big thinker.
He ended up selling his company,
and I made most of
the money back.
And now he's working
on another project.
But if he goes into something
else, I will back him again,
because you sit down with the
person and you know, this
might not be the idea, but
they're going to hit some day.
And they're going to hit big,
because just of who they are.
DON DODGE: Excellent, there are
microphones on either side
here, and I want to encourage
your questions.
So think up questions,
stand at the mic.
I'll recognize you and
have you do it.
I'm going to continue to ask
questions, but if someone
stands up, I'll let you in.
Naval, Angel List.
Angel List has really changed
the early stage angel
investing scene.
Give us some numbers.
How many projects are
on Angel List?
How many have been funded?
How many investors?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: So anyone
can list a project.
That's not hard.
You can just go create
a profile.
So we have 70,000 of those.
Of them, I'd say probably
between 10 and 15,000 are
actually legitimate attempts
at companies.
In other words, people are
thoughtful about if they're
actually going to pursue it.
Of that, I'd say about 3
to 4,000 are probably
finance-able.
And of those maybe 1 in 2,000
have gotten financed.
Not all of that volume get
driven by Angel List.
To some extent we're a listing
service, to some extent we're
a matchmaking service.
On the matchmaking side, we've
probably driven a little over
1,000 of those investments.
We do about 200 introductions
a week between
start-ups and investors.
And we drive right now about
600 introduction in a week
between talent and start-ups.
So if your company fails, and
you want to go join a cool
start-up very early on,
we try and make that
easier for you as well.
And I don't think it's
changed the investing
landscape that much yet.
We're still working on
a lot of things.
It's only a little over
two years old.
I think what's really happened
is the landscape itself has
changed, and we're just more
a reflection of that.
And what's changed is the cost
of building a start-up at
least early on has collapsed.
You can launch and then raise.
You can get really far
in 250 or 500K.
So the set of investors
that are
available to you has expanded.
The number of people playing
has expanded.
Investors can get
more data point.
There's a lot more competition,
a lot more noise,
a lot less signal.
There's a lot of
stuff going on.
So the market is changing very,
very rapidly, and it's
changing in fundamental
structural ways.
And I think a lot that is
happening because we have
these deployment and code
platforms like Amazon and
Google and so on that you can
spread your product on.
We have development platforms.
We have labor platforms,
mechanical turf, and so on.
And now we have capital
platforms, like Angel List and
Kick Starter.
So you combine all that together
and the leverage
available to a modern
entrepreneur is unbelievable.
I was talking to a fellow guy
that I sort of worked
with 10 years ago.
We're coming up the escalator.
I'm like, so what did you used
to do at this company?
We had two companies that
ended up merging.
And he said, oh I used to build
data slicing stuff.
So, oh OK, you had like a team
of 10 people doing manually
what you could with a day
with Solar today, right.
You could just set up
your Solar instance
and you'd be done.
So things have changed,
and it's great.
But it just means it's also
extremely competitive.
And Angel List is a reflection
of that.
As the number of companies
has scaled, the number of
investors has scaled.
The amount of data
you need scales.
The amount of capital
you need goes down.
The information you need has
to be digestible in a
different format.
And so if an Angel List did
not exist it would be
necessary to create it.
DON DODGE: So Angel List has
raised significant money for
over 1,000 companies.
Most recently I read about
Rally, which I think Kevin is
an investor in and Google
Ventures is an investor in.
And they raised 8 million total
and 4 million of that
through Angel List.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yeah, between
4 and 4 and a half.
KEVIN ROSE: That's how I
initially found out about it
was Angel List.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Great,
excellent, I hope
they make you money.
DON DODGE: Raising $4 million
on Angel List, that's pretty
disruptive.
That was never possible
before.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yeah, well
there's a VC firm in there.
And that's one of the dirty
secrets of Angel List is more
than half the flow in capital
comes from venture
capitalists.
There are a lot of VCs playing
the seed market now.
The whole power of the series
A firms has traditionally
derived from being
first money in.
And to the extent that a venture
firm is not able to
play in the first money in
space, they gradually lose
influence and control of
the entrepreneurs.
And what has happened is the
series A firms used to be the
first money in.
These are all the
names you know.
And then in front of them sprung
up the super angels.
Then in front of sprung
up the angels.
And in front of them sprung
up the incubators.
So the chain has gotten
a lot larger now.
A lot the venture capital
firms are now doing seed
investing, and they're trying to
get back to the first money
in principle.
And that is causing huge
pricing and behavior
aberrations in the market,
because to a venture
capitalist, $25 million
out of their fund
is a marketing expense.
They might be perfectly happy
just spending that to build
relationships.
Maybe the next Caleb to your
point, but to an angel or a
seed fund that's your
life blood.
You've got to make money
on that pile.
So we're seeing some really
aberrant behavior in the
market right now.
DON DODGE: So did
you hear that?
Kevin found out about
Rally on Angel List.
So if you don't have any other
avenue to get to investors,
get yourself on Angel List,
and people like us--
I think every one of us is on
Angel List and there are
thousands of investors there.
So that's a good point.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Not to set
expectations crazy, the
reality is we get about a
hundred company profiles
created a day.
80 or 90 of them we could
never look at.
We do algorithmic screens on
them, incomplete profile,
social graph filter, structure
traction, where you went to
school, all that stuff.
Maybe the top 10 or 15 we
actually manually review.
And maybe one every two days
we get to send out.
And there's another one or two
that get funded either
serendipitously or because their
own network on Angel
List shares them.
So it is still, we don't take
your un-financeable company
and make it financeable But
hopefully we can accelerate
financing, get you
more options.
And essentially you can think of
us as running a global spam
filter in the crowd for busy
venture capitalists.
There's no reason why every
VC firm needs to have 10
associates screening
deal flow.
You can just put them all in the
cloud and screen out the
obvious junk.
And then beyond that level,
we're trying to
find fit and judgment.
That's where the human
element comes in.
And to Rich's point, I think I
completely agree that team is
the most important thing.
And so the place where Angel
List and any online network
falls down is on screening
the team.
So we're working very hard on
introducing new features that
help you figure out who the
good people are and how to
screen them and analyze their
backgrounds and at least do
another level of filtering
there, because another thing
any good venture capitalists
will tell you is they usually
know within the first five
minutes if the team is
backable or not.
And then they got to sit through
the next 40 or 50
minutes scheduled on the
calendar, looking at their
watch, trying not to look
at their BlackBerry.
Not because they're rude,
because they're busy and
they've already sort
of decided.
So that should be a more
efficient filtering process.
DON DODGE: I'd like to drill
down more on that in a minute.
But first let's take some
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, I want to
hear about that as well.
And you're also mentioning
some things that are not
understandable to me.
You're talking about
different levels of
pre-investors and all that.
And so I guess my question's
about how do you get an
audience that starts any of
those kinds of things going?
And I guess you mentioned Angel
List, which is helpful.
If you could tell more about
that, and the other part I
have a question of is, a lot of
what you're explaining are
ideas for huge companies,
like the next Pinterest
or whatever it is.
But what about those kind of
medium size, I think I have a
great idea, something that
requires a creative team and
some full time as well.
But we're not talking
about hundreds.
We're talking about
a dozen or so.
So anyways, is there any avenue
for someone to get a
start-up like that and if you
have any advice on that?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I think it's
just a bad road to go down.
If you go to someone, you say
I'm trying to buy something
small and medium sized,
you're un-fundable.
And you're un-fundable, because
in game theory terms,
this is what's called a
Keynesian Beauty Contest,
where each round of judges is
trying to pick what the next
round of judges is
going to pick.
So the problem an angel has
is if you're not going for
something big is, they don't
want to invest in you because
they know that no VC will invest
in you because VCs have
big funds and only want to
go in for big things.
And the VCs don't want to invest
in you, because the
private equity people won't
eventually want
to invest in you.
And because that angel doesn't
want to invest in you,
incubators aren't going to
want to invest in you.
So that knowledge ripples
all the way
back through the chain.
So unless you can build
something or you have a shot,
not everything goes huge
obviously, but if your
aspiration is not to be huge,
you end up un-financeable
That said, a lot of these things
that turn out to be
huge are completely non-obvious
they're going to
be huge in the beginning.
So I don't think you have
to necessarily have an
articulation for how it's
going to be gigantic.
Like I don't think either
Instagram or Pinterest could
have made that argument
credible early on.
AUDIENCE: That's kind of
what I'm getting at.
There's this first step that is,
we show something amazing,
and it has that next--
NAVAL RAVIKANT: But don't shoot
yourself in the foot by
saying we're going to
build something
medium size or small.
That's a huge warning signal.
RICH MINER: By the way,
large can be relative
to a market, too.
The market doesn't need to be
everybody in this room.
But if you can say, there are
these people, they need x.
We think we can get
90% of those guys.
I mean again, there's ways of
saying we're going to crush
this and then grow from there.
But you want to use that
terminology, not the not
aiming high.
KEVIN ROSE: And I think that
I've seen several times that
different angel investors put
money into things that they're
personally passionate about.
And oftentimes it doesn't have
to be a big business it's just
something like I know a buddy
of mine has a ramen shop.
And he got a bunch of tech angel
investors to put money
in the ramen shot.
They're not trying to make
a billion dollar
off the ramen shop.
They just like the
idea, right?
So if you can find those like
minded investors, that's
another potential
avenue for you.
The other thing, too, is
sometimes you just don't need
investment.
I mean you can do
this yourself.
I created a little service
called We Follow that was a
directory for Twitter
users early on.
And it grew to over a million
users adding all their tags
and credentials to it.
And I had some people approach
me saying, do you want to take
some money for this?
And I'm like, no I
don't want to.
This is just a little hobby.
It's running on two servers.
And it ended up, I slapped on
some AdSense ads, and it makes
a couple thousand dollars a
month and pays for awesome
dinners and uber cab rides.
And that's what it does.
And it's awesome, and there's
no employees.
So that's always a potential
way to go as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICH MINER: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I've heard you guys
talk about team and the
importance of people
and different
characteristics of people.
Where does education fall into
that, be it formal informal?
When you view and you talk to
somebody and you talk about
their background a little bit,
where do you put an education,
the importance of their
education, and again, be
informal and formal?
RICH MINER: Now for me
that's a hard one.
I mean I funded college dropouts
that just again
seemed to be wiser than
their years and
their education status.
I work near MIT, but I'm a
graduate of UMass Lowell
school system.
So to me it's really the
person, and it's
how smart they are.
And to me that's something that
is potentially influenced
by degree but really can be
street smarts as well.
So again I think what you don't
want to do is is not
show that you're not educated
in a space you're
trying to get into.
If you're trying to build
something technically complex
from a computer science
standpoint, I want to see
somebody that has some--
to me it's a red flag if there
isn't somebody that has strong
computer science fundamental
background.
And so again I think it's
somewhat adaptable to the
particular opportunity.
But if you're passionate about
something, you've built a
group that you think is
absolutely capable of crushing
it in an area and that they've
got skills that you think you
can convince people, pedigree in
my mind isn't as important
as being able to convince
people of those previous
attributes I mentioned.
DON DODGE: Bill Gates
dropped out.
He did OK.
Sean Fanning, he attended one
semester of college and he
dropped out, and he's
done OK, too.
So it's more about the passion,
and the drive, and
getting things done than it is
a piece of paper from some
university.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Education is one
those weird markets where
sort of the least educated
people are often the least
intelligence.
But that's correlation,
not causation.
And then you've got a set
of people who are highly
intelligent and highly
educated.
And at the top there's
the most intelligent.
They're usually the least
educated again.
So they get confused with
that other bundle.
So you can't use it as
a filter function.
But you can use it
as a signal.
So what you really want to see
is you want to see evidence of
intelligence and drive
bundled together.
One way could be 3.9 at MIT in
double E. Another way could
be, dropped out of school, did
some amazing open source
project, got a million
followers, right?
So it's just a signal.
It's data.
DON DODGE: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you a lot of
us in the room are starting
mobile app companies.
And I was wondering, when do
you guys like to invest in
seed rounds as far as the
product life cycle?
Do you like when it's just
screenshots, clickable demo,
out in the market, first beta?
When should we really
go and try and raise
that first seed round?
DON DODGE: Good question.
RICH MINER: I mean I'll
give you my--
I mean to me it's a very hard
question to answer, because
it's almost different
every single time.
I mean certainly if it's a
repeat entrepreneur, which you
probably wouldn't be in this
case, they might have money
chasing them before they have
some sketches down.
It really comes back to the
people and what you get from
them in terms of what
they're building.
And that can maybe just be
conveyed with some sketches,
and a passionate group, and a
picture of what they want to
build and where they
want to take it.
And they're able to articulate
that clearly.
Some people they might speak all
the words, but you can't
get that image in your mind.
And you really do need we need
to see a functional prototype
about what they're
talking about.
Sometimes with a functional
prototype you're still not
convinced that that's going to
capture the consumer's appeal,
and you actually want to see
it out in the market and
gathering some traction.
But literally it's all across
that spectrum for me, and it's
case by case.
AUDIENCE: Because I think we
hear a lot about traction, how
important traction is.
And, come back to me when you
have traction is something
that I think is said a lot.
And I just was wondering how
much truth there is to that
and is it bad for us to go up
and try and raise a round when
we don't have any
traction because
we're not in the market?
RICH MINER: I think you should
always trying to find somebody
and say, look can you just take
a look at what I'm doing.
I'm not pitching you.
This is a friendly meeting.
Can you give me feedback?
And I bet you will find
people willing to
give you some feedback.
KEVIN ROSE: I think come back
when you have traction is a
fancy way of just saying, I
don't believe in what you're
building right now.
I think that it's nice to have
a working prototype,
especially given how fast--
if you can prototype something
up real quick, it doesn't
matter if it's on the app store
or not, if it's just
working on your phone.
And it's also a great
way to pitch people.
I've had people come up to me
at a bar or a function, or
something like that and
say, hey I need 30
seconds of your time.
I just want to show you
this app real quick.
And if it's something I can
look at rather than like
whispering over, so
my idea is this.
It's like it's so much better
to play with it.
So if you can build something,
even if there's no back end
associated with that to where
you can just walk through it
with your fingers,
I mean do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DON DODGE: Great, over here.
AUDIENCE: So coming from an
East Coast, Massachusetts
suburbs and not really knowing
any VCs or ins in a Silicon
Valley-esque area, what would
you suggest for a path in
getting your idea recognized by
VCs or mentors who can help
out with getting your
idea right on track?
I know I'm probably not
alone in a unique
situation or anything.
But just seeing myself and my
friends, we want to make
something really cool.
What would you suggest?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: It sounds
stupid, but build something
really cool and the world will
beat a path to your door.
I really think that, especially
in Silicon Valley.
Because if you're in the venture
or the angel business,
you're hunting for great
people and great ideas.
If you're going around, to
Kevin's point, if you're
yelling your idea in a crowded
bar, that's not going to get
you very far.
If you're walking around with
something really cool that
people are crowding around,
that's going to
get you pretty far.
If someone downloads something
of yours off the app store and
they're like wow, this is
a really great app,
they'll call you.
So the best way to get
noticed is just to
build something great.
I have never gone out and tried
to raise a dollar for
Angel List.
I get offers all day long,
because I just keep working on
it, and the offers
keep coming in.
So I know that sounds very
much like build it
and they will come.
But in the case of Silicon
Valley investors, it actually
is very much true.
That said, you can't walk 20
feet here without tripping
over an investor.
And you have lots and lots of
connections in common with
them or you'll form
them very quickly.
You ask path, one of the things
we do on Angel List is
you come in, you connect your
social networks, and we show
you your six degrees of
separation path to any
investor on the site.
So you can figure out who you
have in common, LinkedIn,
Twitter, Facebook, whatever.
So you can always get there, but
I would say focus on the
product first and investment
second.
The investment will come when
the product is ready.
KEVIN ROSE: I would also throw
in there that when you're
building your product, do it
in a social environment.
Like head out to some of these
coffee shops in San Francisco
that everyone gathers around.
I mean there's so many start-ups
around here just
like in coffee shops, meeting
each other, hanging out.
There's social events that
happen all the time.
Get on some of these
calendars.
Look at some of these different
start-up groups and
organizations that are out
there and just network.
You really have to network
and meet new people.
And you'll be connected up with
angels and the people
that you want to know within
a month or two max.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: The good news
is if you're a builder,
there's more networkers
in the system
than there are builders.
It's like in biology where there
are more parasites than
there are self-standing
host creatures.
There's about six times
as many parasites.
I'm not calling them parasites
necessarily.
KEVIN ROSE: Are we the
parasites then?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yeah, but
there's a lot more networkers
in the system that there
are actually builders.
There are a lot fewer
builders.
It's like in Hollywood.
There are a lot fewer actors and
directors than there are
all surrounding support cast.
So that support cast
will find you.
If you're sitting in a coffee
shop and you're coding
something up cool and showing
really neat demos, believe me,
like 20 people will come
out of the woodwork.
And your table will be full.
And they'll be trying to figure
out how to help you,
because all value in Silicon
Valley originates from the
builders, and those are
the scarcest resource.
So if you're a builder, the
ecosystem will find you.
I think your problem is going
to be the opposite, which is
going to be how to figure out
which network or connector to
go through who doesn't like take
you to the wrong place,
or isn't very smart, or tries
to take a cut, or screws up
your company somehow.
RICH MINER: So full disclosure,
I'm actually a
Boston-based venture
capitalist, not Silicon Valley.
So I mean in your particular
case, just come
into Boston, Cambridge.
I mean all of the VCs
have moved back into
the Cambridge area.
It's a very dense, vibrant
environment
around Kendall Square.
Go online, check VentureFizz,
and some other resources.
You'll see literally almost
every day of the week there
are start-up meet-ups
in the evening or
coffees in the morning.
Bijan from Spark and Nabeel from
Spark do a venture coffee
once a week.
They're not always there, but
there typically are other VCs
and other start-ups.
So Boston is a pretty vibrant
start-up environment that's
typically number 2 to Silicon
Valley historically.
So head into town, and you'll
meet up with people.
DON DODGE: I have two pieces
of advice for you.
Number one, the best path to
starting a start-up is to work
at a start-up.
So the first thing I would
do is join a start-up.
Learn how a start-up
gets built.
Learn how they attract
investors.
customers.
Learn how they attract
employees.
Get into that ecosystem.
That's the best training for
doing a start-up is to work at
a start-up.
The second way is network
with friends.
Find friends who are working
at a start-up or who have
started a company, and they will
lead you to investors and
other people.
So those are two
ways to do it.
But Naval's right.
If you're a builder, they will
just come and find you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, I have a
start-up that is in the early
traction stage and an investor
that has instructed me to go
build a team.
And I found it very difficult
to find people that are
qualified and understand that
long-term commitment that you
were talking Naval.
Are there channels that
you can recommend.
I kind of feel like sitting on
the sidewalk with a cardboard
sign at this stage.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: That's
a tough one.
Yeah there's two things in a
start-up that matter, selling
and building.
And this is the hardest sales
thing right now, which is
you've got to convince
people to join your
vision and your dream.
To Don's point, the reason why
I think it's so important to
work in a start-up is to build
up a great alumni network.
The people who have done the
best over the years are the
ones who just had incredible
alumni networks coming out.
Look at what the early Googlers
went on to do or what
the Paypal mafia went on to
do, just unbelievable.
So I would say you have to reach
back into your start-up
alumni networks.
Other than that, I can tell you
when I started Angel List
it was a [INAUDIBLE].
Try recruiting an engineer
into that.
It's like the least exciting
thing on the planet.
You've got a user base of 25
people running a mailing list.
But the reality is just as you
build it up, it will get
easier and easier to recruit.
Now we turn away candidates.
So it's just, you got
to build traction.
So you can look at your
alumni networks.
You can build traction.
By the way, the code from this
investor saying you've got to
build a team might just be,
I don't believe in you.
So just--
investors say no in many
different ways, because it's
very hard to look at
someone and say--
AUDIENCE: Actually, he's already
written a check.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: So he's
written a check?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: OK,
that's good.
So they do believe there.
I guess this is part of the test
of being an entrepreneur.
Can you recruit?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DON DODGE: Hold on a second.
If you drill down on why team
is so important, if you look
at why that's true, it's because
if you can attract
another founder or two founders
who believe in your
idea so much that they're
willing to stop what they're
doing and join you, then that's
validation that your
idea might have some legs.
It's also when investors
look at that team.
They say, wow here's two or
three guys that have had
experience doing other things.
They've come together to try
to make this idea work.
It's additional validation.
So that's why single founders
almost never get funded.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICH MINER: I don't know what
you're building, but you
mentioned you're getting
traction.
So that's a network that you've
started to build.
You might want to find some way
to leverage the community
of people with whom your product
has traction with to
let that community know
that you're hiring.
AUDIENCE: That's a good point.
KEVIN ROSE: I would say also
you have to go after--
find individuals that you really
respect and hunt them
down and convince them to
join your start-up.
I did something very similar to
this when in 2004 I was a
big fan of the Mozilla website,
and the Firefox work,
and the Firefox logo.
And I found out one of the guys
behind this, his name is
Daniel Burka, and he lived in
Canada, and he was a designer.
And he was doing a bunch
of design work.
Mozilla was one of
his clients.
And I finally got
a hold of him.
And I was like, give me
a week of your time.
I'll pay you.
Come on as a freelancer.
Give me a week of your time.
I just want you think through
some of these issues, work on
some of the usability
problems I'm having.
And so we got together.
He flew into San Francisco.
We worked on some this stuff.
We became friends.
We had a lot of fun.
I showed him around the city.
He thought the city
was awesome.
I convinced him to move
out here from Canada.
We got him a visa, and he
joined the company.
It was a long road.
It was like a three or
four month process
to make this happen.
But it finally happened.
So just find those rock stars
that you want to go after if
you know of any.
And hunt them down
and convince them
to join your start-up.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I'm not
as good as Kevin.
It takes me 6 to 12 months
to recruit somebody good.
From the moment I identity them
and start courting them
it's a 6 to 12 month process.
And it's like you're trying to
get someone to break up with
their significant other and
end their relationship.
So you kind of have to wait
for the low point.
And so you just have
to hang out there.
Be friendly.
Make them offers.
Take them out for drinks.
And then that month when they
happen to be having a bad
time, then you swoop in.
It's a long process.
RICH MINER: And don't worry
about being shameless.
Send candy, send the
spouse flowers.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I've had
to pitch spouses.
Go in there with a PowerPoint
and pitch the spouse.
AUDIENCE: Exactly, thank you.
DON DODGE: We have lots of
questions out here, and I want
to make sure that we
get to all of them.
So a couple of rules,
no commercials, no
pitches, just questions.
And try to make them short so
that we can get through as
many as possible.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
am from India.
And I'm doing a start-up
there.
Getting some traction, but when
I was listening to the
panel, I heard you say that
there is this chain.
The angels have to
sell to VCs.
The VCs have to sell to the PEs,
and so on and so forth.
Just wanted to ask this
question, is it better to
raise angel in India, or will
it help if I actually raise
angel in the US?
And how do I go about it?
Is Angel List OK with an Indian
trying to raise angel
money in the US?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: If you have
traction and you're based
here, at least for some period
of time, like you're here for
a month or two, you can raise
money from US investors.
There are a lot of ex-Indian
origin angels
now in the US area.
So we can help there.
But you need to have traction,
because people don't want to
invest around the world unless
there's something there.
You can also find
local investors.
A company called Freshdesk
that raised money through
Angel List that's in India
from Indian investors.
So it happens.
It's just rarer.
And hopefully we'll get more
Indian investors on.
But I would say India is
probably geography number six
or seven for us in
terms of volume.
Obviously Silicon
Valley's huge.
The fact that you're out here
already means you're on the
right track.
DON DODGE: You should
join TIE.
Have you heard of TIE?
AUDIENCE: I'm a member
of TIE, yes.
DON DODGE: It's a good start.
AUDIENCE: It's again question
about team.
I several times didn't receive
money from angels, venture
capitalists, because of
lack of the team.
I'm inventor with several
inventions, many of them I
think marketable.
Right now I'm concentrated on
the one-off technologies, and
we are a successful,
[INAUDIBLE].
But line of technologies waiting
for entrepreneurs.
Same I have a lot of same
crazy inventors.
They not able raise money
because of lack of the team.
My question is, you have any
institution like venture
entrepreneurs like venture
capitalists?
And something that maybe
even could be another
idea for your venture?
RICH MINER: I mean I think in a
lot of VCs' minds there's a
big difference between an
inventor and an entrepreneur.
And it sounds like you've
stumbled on that, because I
think just the idea itself
without the passion and the
understanding as to how you're
going to get that to blossom
within some community
is a big gap.
One thing you might want to do
is this is where being around
some of the business schools
might be helpful, because
there you often have people
that understand markets,
commercialization, they have a
passion for doing a start-up.
But they need the technical
idea, concept, invention, or
something that they can
bring to market.
So that might be one way to
start complementing some of
the skills for the things that
you've put together and seeing
if you can get somebody who has
that passion, fire in the
belly, and some of the
education and the
understanding as to how you make
a company out of that.
AUDIENCE: Ask if any maybe
institution like I don't know
that offering service as
entrepreneurs or that's could
be a piece of the puzzle
necessary for the inventors.
RICH MINER: The problem is
most entrepreneurs are
passionate about
their own idea.
DON DODGE: That's back to why
team is so important.
Entrepreneurs are so passionate
about their own
ideas, the hardest part is to
get somebody to drop their
idea to join you on your idea.
And then that's validation
that you have
something really big.
So without that, it's going
to be very difficult.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
DON DODGE: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering what
type of analysis do you do
when a market is very large,
but the barrier of
entry is very high.
So something where there's a
lot of regulatory state and
federal hurdles that you have to
go through, but the market
is actually much bigger
than most markets.
But the tech in that market
is actually very low.
DON DODGE: Like health care
or energy or those areas?
AUDIENCE: Yes, not actually
those areas but something--
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Those kinds
of markets tend to have
specialized investors who know
how to handicap the risks of
the regulatory strategies.
And most investors who are not
familiar with those markets
tend not to go into that.
That's why you have dedicated
clean tech VCs or biotech VCs.
If no VC exists in that market,
like that market is
literally that new, then you
have to go find other
entrepreneurs or executives
who managed to crack that
market before and might be
willing to be angels.
But you just got to find people
with domain expertise.
And you can use CrunchBase, or
Angel List, or Google and
track down people.
RICH MINER: Getting someone to
believe in you who has scaled
of one of those walls before,
who has brought a product in
front of the FDA before or
whatever to say, I'm now
working with these guys.
I believe in what they're doing,
and I can help them get
over that hurdle.
That's probably what
you want to do.
AUDIENCE: It's a market I've
been in for a long time, and
it's definitely different
and outside of anything
California-based or anything
that's very trendy.
So just curious if you take
those types of risks and how
you analyze those
types of risk.
DON DODGE: There are investors
who do, but I don't
think that's us.
AUDIENCE: So what's the typical
range of investment at
a seed round, and what do
investors want in return, like
how much would they want?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Probably depend
on the company, but the
averages these days for what's
called a seed round is around
250K to a million and normally
sell about 20% of a company.
DON DODGE: Good answer.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick two part.
So if you feel like you
do have a great team.
You've got a disruptive idea.
But you're going into market
where there are big
competitors that could copy
quickly and adopt to that
idea, what would be your
recommendation for that
company in terms of posting for
crowdsourcing, posting to
Angel List, trying to
find it that way?
And then if you guys have time
at the end, what's the
craziest pitch you've gotten
from an entrepreneur or the
craziest way they've gotten a
hold of you to do that pitch?
RICH MINER: On your first point,
I just find people
don't copy quickly.
I'd just go for it.
If you think it's a big idea
and you have a great team,
first of all send Kevin
or I an email.
But just go for it.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: You're going to
have the opposite problem.
The problem you're going to have
is going to be shouting
your product and idea from
the rooftops and
nobody will want it.
That's the most likely case.
I have even gone through the
whole secrecy thing as an
entrepreneur myself, and I
always regret it later,
because all it does is it slows
down the process of
getting partners, getting
customers, getting investors,
getting feedback.
And the reality is if your
idea truly can be copied
easily, and if big companies are
somehow inclined to copy
it easily, and if somehow they
can get through their
bureaucracy and priorities
and do it,
then you're dead anyway.
So figure that out sooner
rather than later.
Figure that out in one year
instead of 10 years.
DON DODGE: That's a huge point,
that some first-time
entrepreneurs miss.
They try to keep their
idea secret.
Or they ask people
to sign NDAs.
It's not going to happen.
You want to shout your idea from
the rooftops to see who's
going to be attracted to it.
Don't worry about somebody
copying your idea.
Two reasons--
one is, as I said earlier,
entrepreneurs are passionate
about their idea.
They're totally focused
on their idea.
They don't care what
your idea is.
They care what their ideas is.
So getting them to pay attention
to your idea is the
hardest thing in the world.
Don't worry about big companies
copying your idea.
Google has a list of thousands
of ideas that we
have yet to get to.
They aren't going to drop--
RICH MINER: And even some
of the ones we have.
DON DODGE: Yes so, big companies
don't copy other
ideas very often, because they
have a million ideas
themselves that they want
to get to that they
don't have time for.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I would say
that out of 10 or 15,000
pitches that we've reviewed at
Angel List in the last two
years, which is probably the
most of any human on the
planet, we've probably seen two
or three unique ideas and
not in a good way.
KEVIN ROSE: I think that
features get copied.
Ideas really don't get copied.
You see a lot of different
innovation on little tiny
features, pull to refresh,
whatever it may be.
And all of a sudden a big
company will see that, say oh
that's interesting, that fits
into what we're doing.
And then if it's easy to
implement, they'll do that.
But if it's really an idea, a
unique big idea, I agree, big
companies don't move
that fast.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you've made some
analogies to marriage and
creating a start-up.
As someone who's married,
someone who's working at a
successful company who makes a
pretty good living, can you
give any advice of how you can
determine if you really should
throw yourself into this pet
of a start-up, because I'm
somewhat paralyzed with--
I'm confident I have an idea
that I think could be
successful.
But I'm standing kind of at the
edge, and I don't know how
to jump into that.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: It's
like marriage.
If you have to think about
it, the answer is no.
DON DODGE: Exactly right, it
is exactly like marriage.
If you can't think about
anything else, if you can't
imagine not moving forward with
this person or with this
idea, that's when you
get married, that's
when you start a company.
If you're not totally convinced
and totally
passionate, don't get married
and don't start a company.
KEVIN ROSE: You could approach
it like dating, though, and
just do it on the
side at night.
AUDIENCE: The thing is I'm
married, have two kids.
It's really the--
how do you sacrifice
the potential?
You've got this potential in
front of you and you've got
this stability.
And it's trying to figure out,
is it worth dropping the
stability for this huge risk?
RICH MINER: I mean there's
definitely a risk trade-off.
And it's harder when you're a
little bit further along in
life and have the size.
But I mean to Kevin's point, I
wouldn't take that lightly.
You've got friends.
You can get some
of other people
passionate about the idea.
As we've said up here before,
a lot of things can be built
relatively easily these days.
So depending on the nature of
whatever sort of NDAs you're
under and things within your
company that you're currently
employed by, if you can move
something along or have some
other people that you're working
with help move it
along, that will decrease the
risk potentially around the
concept, because it'll maybe
start to get some traction or
proof of concept.
And if you can get your
threshold to where, Yeah now I
really see it.
Now I feel like I can do it.
Now I do feel like I can jump
from what I'm doing to go
raise some money for that, it's
a good way to get over
that hurdle.
AUDIENCE: Just do it then
is what you're saying.
KEVIN ROSE: It sounds
like you have skills
as a backup, right?
So if this doesn't work out, you
can always go back to it.
And when you're laying there on
your death bed at 90 years
old, are you going to be pissed
that you took a leap
and tried something
crazy and fun?
Probably not, right?
Go do it.
AUDIENCE: Just do it, right.
Thanks.
DON DODGE: So let me just add
on that point, because I get
this question at least once a
week, where someone has a
great idea, and they say they
have a few friends that are
working with them nights and
weekends to do things.
And they say, if I could only
raise money, then I could
convince them all to
quit their jobs
and go do the thing.
It happens every week.
And I tell them, look from an
investor point of view, if you
aren't passionate about it, if
you don't believe in it enough
to quit your job and go do it,
why should I believe in it?
Why should I give you my money
if you don't even believe in
it enough to jump into
it and do it?
So think about that.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: At least from
your own personal payback as
an entrepreneur, you have to
be process focused, not
outcome focused.
Otherwise it's like saying,
I'm getting
married to have kids.
My kids better go to Harvard.
If I get married to you and our
kids don't go to Harvard
I'll be really disappointed.
So it's sort of a ludicrous
thing to just
go for the end goal.
You literally have to enjoy the
process, because most of
the time it will end in tears.
So you better have fun
along the way.
And if you're outcome focused,
then I wouldn't do it.
And that's not judgmental.
I've been outcome focused
most of my life.
But you're going to end
up in a bad place.
AUDIENCE: So you guys
have done a lot of
talking about start-ups.
And from what I've seen you guys
investing in, a lot of it
seems to be consumer Internet
start-ups and things that are
going to get mass market.
But a lot of the stuff I've
worked on is kind of small
business or indie dev focused
in that kind of market.
How does that change
things when
you're looking at investing?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: There are tons
of start-ups out there.
There are tons of them
getting funded.
So I get this question
every panel.
Somebody gets up and says, we're
doing enterprise and you
guys only do consumer, and, oh,
woe is me, life is so hard
at enterprise.
Not true, life is harder
at consumer, because
there's more of them.
They're less differentiated.
The few that are get funded
have breakout traction.
And you're just seeing the
weight of solid evidence.
Their hit rate might
be 1 and 100.
Yours is 1 in 10.
But there's so fewer of you that
you don't notice that.
Look at the most celebrated
recent exit, Yammer, at 20
times revenues, 1.2
billion in cash.
A huge bidding war, private
market valuation has gone from
$250 million a year ago to $500
million six months ago to
a $1.2 billion exit.
If you can't raise money in a
small business offering on the
back of that, then I would argue
you're not building a
good product.
Don't let the market
hold you back.
There are plenty of investors
who are looking for enterprise
or small business or developer
facing products that know how
to get traction and
can eventually end
up in a large market.
DON DODGE: I invest in
B2B businesses and
enterprise type stuff.
I would say enterprise is
where the money is.
Consumer is where
the users are.
You can be successful at both.
But what we're seeing with
Yammer and some of the others
is this fusion of consumer
and enterprise.
So social enterprise
if you will.
Huge opportunities there.
You get the traction
from the consumers.
You get the money from
the enterprise.
Huge opportunities for any kinds
of companies that are
taking enterprise software and
leveraging consumer aspects.
AUDIENCE: So we keep talking
about risk management.
It's all about risk
management.
We talk about money to reduce
risk what we're doing.
Can you speak about more things
that VC firms provide
besides capital.
That's just like the main thing
we focus on nowadays.
Like TechCrunch says so and so
got x amount of dollars and
whatever, but they don't talk
about the other aspects to it.
I think most people are not
aware about what I should get
from a VC firm besides cash.
RICH MINER: And by the way I
think that's a great point.
As much as you're out raising
money, you should also be
interviewing the people who you
take money from and make
sure that you're taking money
from people who are going to
be good money--
at least not a problem
for you.
And hopefully are going
to be able to help
and add some value.
Most VCs minimally are going to
be able to write a check,
have some knowledge from their
past experience and also have
a good network.
In the case of Google Ventures,
we also have a bunch
of vertical domains of
expertise, some great guys
that are super good at--
we have a whole design practice
that helps our
portfolio companies build
brilliant, beautiful, simple,
easy to use products.
We have recruiters that help
our portfolio companies
recruit in new engineers
onto their team.
We have architects and platform
specialists who help
our companies build Google
scale products, because
they've done that at Google.
So we look at all the things
that Google has done well.
And help our portfolio company
do all of those
things really well.
All VCs have varying degrees
of some value add
that they can bring.
But you should definitely dig in
to what they're going to do
to help you out and build
your company.
AUDIENCE: So how do you narrow
down the VC firms?
What things do you look for
besides the capital aspects?
How do you help narrow
that down?
Is there pre-defined general
guidelines to that?
RICH MINER: You'll be a good
situation if you're able to
have that many people interested
that you're
narrowing it down.
But the best thing to do is
ask them for some CEOs of
other companies that
they've funded.
Or try and find that yourself
as well and get those
reference checks, just like
they'll do the same on you.
KEVIN ROSE: You should also
check in with them and figure
out how much of their
time you're actually
going to get as well.
I mean one of the things that,
when Digg finally had some
traction and we were able to go
and kind of pick out who we
wanted to work with from a VC
standpoint, I remember we took
some money from Reid Hoffman and
actually and from David Z
at Greylock.
And David was more than willing
to come in almost
every other week and sit down
with us and help us through
some of our issues and have that
frank conversation, say,
I like what you've built, your
portfolio is awesome.
But when are we going to get
to meet and how often?
And how can you help me?
I think your point
of interviewing
them is a great one.
AUDIENCE: So are you nervous
about getting married.
Is that why you're nervous now
with all this marriage talk?
KEVIN ROSE: Yeah a little bit.
That's not till next
year, though.
AUDIENCE: I'm from Mexico, and
a couple of friends and me, I
have a little start-up
there in Mexico City.
My question is you talked about
the importance of being
in the ecosystem,
being surrounded
by all these start-ups.
And our main market is in
Mexico, in Latin America.
But I don't know if it would
be a nice idea to come here
out to Silicon Valley to
mix with the ecosystem.
And bring all these ideas,
and take it to our
own start-up in Mexico.
I don't know.
KEVIN ROSE: I think one of the
things that needs to happen is
there needs to be people like
you in other cities that go
out and drive the start-up
culture for that city.
I've seen people try to do
this in smaller cities.
I have some friends that
live in Redding,
California, little tiny city.
And they go out and find a
person with the largest
Twitter account.
And they hunt that
person down.
They get them to tweet out that
they're going to do a
meet-up at a bar.
I actually did this in Boulder,
Colorado, a few years
ago when it was first starting
to explode over there.
And we had 30, 40
people come out.
And everyone got together.
They were interested in
start-ups and we met up.
And there wasn't that coffee
culture that you have here in
San Francisco.
So this was a way to get
everyone together at a certain
point during the week, and we
talked about start-ups.
And that's how we kicked
things off.
And if you go out there today,
and you do the same tweet,
it's going to be hundreds
of people.
I think that you need to find
these other entrepreneurs, sit
down with them, and
build a culture.
It can be done anywhere.
You just need to really
put in the time and
effort to make it happen.
AUDIENCE: Actually well in
Mexico City we have this
little group of start-up
people.
Here it's bigger.
So maybe, I don't know if my
market is there, but I move
here, I don't know, a
year or half a year.
It would be like
counterproductive, because I'm
away from my market.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: It's good to
spend a little bit of time
here, just because it'll force
you to up your game.
You'll be playing with
the best athletes.
It's like if you wanted to learn
how to make movies and
you were making a movie,
you could do it
anywhere in the world.
But it would be great if you'd
spend a little bit of time in
Hollywood to understand
how they make movies.
Or if you want to do theater,
you spend a little bit of time
in New York.
So it's good to spend a little
bit of time and have some
connections out here.
But you don't need to be based
here all the time if
everything you're building
is in Mexico.
RICH MINER: I don't think any
of us would encourage you to
transplant yourself from where
you're comfortable, where your
market is, where your
connections are.
And there's also nothing wrong
with being a big fish in a
small pond if you really can
shout out and have a loud
voice where you are.
But I think the point is, try
and find some way of getting
that magic that is the essence
of the valley or the
entrepreneurial spirit
and bring it back
to where you are.
DON DODGE: We only have
five minutes left.
We're moving into
lightning round.
So lightning round is you ask
a question less than 30
seconds, and we'll give you
a 30 second answer.
AUDIENCE: So I hope this
resonates with other people.
And I like the reference
to athletes.
So think of like, I could go for
a year right now with my
own personal finances.
I think I'm at the
top of my game.
I've built a service-based
company.
I'm not convinced that
any of my own ideas
are the one to do.
Wondering, any suggestions
on--
I don't want to chase the money,
I don't want to talk to
VCs or angels because I
don't have that idea.
What I do want is I want to work
with other individuals
who need to build something and
need technical expertise.
Yeah how do you do that?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: You're like the
rarest, most valuable man
in the valley.
KEVIN ROSE: Run, because you'll
be chased out of here.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Go join some
great start-up early on whose
mission you can get behind, and
they'll give you a lot of
equity and a lot of
responsibility.
And you'll learn how to do a
start-up and maybe you'll come
along with your own thing
eventually and want to leave
and go do that.
But in the meantime you'll build
a great alumni network,
you'll learn on their dime.
And you won't have--
being an entrepreneur exposes
you to the ultimate level of
stress, because you're the
last line of defense.
And so you don't want to be in
that mental stress situation
unless you have to.
So you're in a position where
you can go join a start-up
that's small but working on
something important with good
people and still get
a lot of equity.
And people like you are
gold right now.
AUDIENCE: And where
do you find those?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Angel List
talent, Angel [INAUDIBLE].
A thousand start-ups recruiting
like their first
engineer, their first
non-founding
engineer, or even founders.
AUDIENCE: At the founder
level, not engineers.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: That's fine.
They're recruiting
founders too.
RICH MINER: You can
also talk to VCs.
Basically to this point VCs
would love to find you.
If they think there's a match
with one of their portfolio
companies, they'll
connect you up.
AUDIENCE: Can you guys talk
about how you hear countless
ideas and you turn them
away or whatever.
They don't appeal to you.
As an entrepreneur, if you catch
the eye of an investor,
but you don't get a good vibe
from them, maybe you feel that
they're going to hinder on your
project or whatever it is
that you're working on, have you
ever had a situation where
you're denied, like somebody
doesn't want to work with you?
And as an entrepreneur, would
you ever encourage somebody to
decline money from a VC if you
felt that they just weren't on
the same wavelength as you?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I think
you answered your own
question but yes.
DON DODGE: Yes, I've advised
entrepreneurs to turn down
money from investors that were
not going to be helpful.
They were sharks.
So don't do it.
AUDIENCE: So if you have a group
of guys that are just
kind of putting something
together, what does that look
like, the kind of going from
just a group of guys to OK,
now we have seed money.
And you're ready to go as far
as equity goes and all that
kind of stuff.
I mean do you work that out
before you talk to the guys,
the money, and then just kind of
figure that out beforehand?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Yeah,
beforehand.
A lot of good writing's
on it online.
Generally even splits work
better but not always.
AUDIENCE: And then as far as
just getting other people that
aren't part of that core team to
do work, paying them out of
funds internally and stuff
like that, does that--
it always comes up, the split.
The split of the company always
seems like something
that people stumble over.
KEVIN ROSE: I've always believed
that if it's your
idea, and you're the one
bringing the idea to the
table, no one else helped
contribute to that idea, you
should have obviously the
bulk of the company.
And then figure out who you're
going to hire, and then give
them percentages based on the
fact that you're hiring that
individual and they're not
really a co-founder with you.
If you're partnering up with
someone that is collaborating
with you and actually
contributing to the idea,
that's a different case.
AUDIENCE: Coming from as a
computer science background,
do you have any quick
suggestions for figuring out
the business side of things
without having like a trial by
fire or getting an MBA at
a really early stage?
DON DODGE: Get a business
co-founder.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: I wouldn't
even look for business.
I'd look for someone
who can sell.
AUDIENCE: Perfect intro, how do
I find a co-founder if I'm
not a people person?
DON DODGE: Build and
they will find you.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: Go
to a meet-up and
have a drink, or two.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about, there's a bunch of
companies popping up
to do development
services for equity.
I have a company that focuses on
building MEBs for start-up
for a mixture of cash and equity
and I'm curious to hear
how does an investor view a
company in the seed stage or
beyond whose product
was built by an
outsourced team basically.
RICH MINER: I discount
it a little bit.
I mean it depends.
If it was just to get somebody
running, but they know who
they're going to hire is going
to be able to build the
product, but if I don't see
the technical expertise to
take that or do it in-house or
understand it, then it's a big
discount for me.
NAVAL RAVIKANT: For me
it's a fatal signal.
I wouldn't invest in a company
that outsources core tech
development.
AUDIENCE: So if you're trying to
raise money for a consumer
play, but there's also a B2B
aspect of it that could make
money, do you look down on
something that has a revenue
stream that's not part of the
core long-term vision, like do
you start looking at the
valuation in terms of the
revenue, or is it you see
the larger consumer
play part of it?
Would you rather see not
generate any revenue and just
focus on consumer, or is it OK
to have that little revenue?
NAVAL RAVIKANT: You
can do either one.
Just do one thing.
DON DODGE: OK, we're at
the end of our show.
We have to stop unfortunately.
So please join me in thanking
our panel for
answering your questions.